This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Scenti Mental. Acquare the competences
这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。您是否有意愿去做出真正的改变？LaCite学院为您提供“依赖与心理健康”课程。获取相关能力
essential to accompany and support the people confronted to the challenges. Construise a career enriching to service of the community francophone of all the
对于陪伴和支持那些面临挑战的人们至关重要。建立一份丰富的职业生涯，为各地的法语社区服务。
country. Don't the quality in French. It's possible with the CIT. Visit Collage LaC. .a.
不要让法语的质量打折扣。在CIT一切皆有可能。请访问Collage LaC. .a.
Today, Souttened by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder
今天，由加拿大卫生部支持。那些眼睛里空无一物。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。人们醒醒吧。我是那个目睹了谋杀案发生的人，凶手是Krivac和DePippo。
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）在被判处最高刑罚后毫无悔意，显得泰然自若。我说我没有罪。我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。在Bone Valley订阅源中收听《魔鬼采石场》，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。
Joy is essential, and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Cotfi is presented by CVS.
快乐至关重要，但也难以捉摸，但现在有一种令人兴奋的新方式来开启您通往更快乐生活的旅程——《快乐101》。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby）主持的新播客。如果您渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的节目。打开您免费的IHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《快乐101》并立即收听。《快乐101》由CVS呈现。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez, and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast.
每个人都视我为足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何面对问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、纯粹的。只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·埃尔南德斯（Javier Hernandez），请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。
June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do.
六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Chams》播客中，我们正在与文化界最热门的人物交谈，比如斯韦·李（Swae Lee）。你意识到你有多传奇了吗？我很感激。我看到了，但我还是觉得，伙计，我还有很多事情要做。
Like, Prince, he dropped, like, 30 albums. We dropped, like, five right now. That's the rate we got to be going. Yeah, that's a good attitude. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Bible.
比如王子（Prince），他发行了大约30张专辑。我们现在才发行了大约5张。这就是我们必须达到的速度。是的，那是个好态度。无论什么时代，《Drink Chams》都会为您带来最大牌的嘉宾和最直白的对话。请收听来自《Drink Chams》的节目。
Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello, everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show.
黑人效应播客网络（Black Effect Podcast Network），可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好，我是杰玛·斯派克（Gemma Spike），欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们探讨二十多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目。
Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. In fact, back for a special little bonus episode from me to you, just for my OG audio listeners. You guys know the drill with these smaller episodes. I feel like there are some topics that are so, so interesting, but also deeply understood. However, they just don't warrant like a full 30 to 45 minute episode. There's like only so much that I can ramble on, only so many tangents that I can go on, unfortunately. but I still want to talk about them. I still want to talk about it. I still think a lot of it
欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一集。事实上，这是我为你准备的一期特别的小奖励节目，专门为我的老听众准备。你们知道这些短节目的套路。我觉得有些话题非常非常有趣，但也被深刻地理解了。然而，它们并不值得做成完整的30到45分钟的节目。不幸的是，我能唠叨的也就这么多，能跑题的也就这么多。但我还是想谈谈它们。我还是想谈谈它。我仍然认为其中很多内容
would be interesting, not just for me to research, but for you guys to hear. Today's episode is one of those topics because we are talking about frontal lobe development. And the recently, I would say recently, like insanely popular idea that our frontal lobe only fully develops at 25. And kind of the reasoning that therefore, you know, we can't really trust any decisions that we make before then. We don't really know who we are until then. And the sense that, you know, you wake up at 25 and suddenly, like, the world just makes sense. Suddenly, like, this is when real adult life begins. I've seen so many people online describe this, like, almost like a sensory feeling of what it feels like to turn 25 and to experience this like seismic shift in their identity and maturity
会很有趣，不仅对我研究来说，对你们听众来说也是如此。今天的节目就是其中一个话题，因为我们要谈论前额叶皮层的发展。以及最近，我应该说最近，极其流行的观点，即我们的前额叶皮层要到25岁才完全发育。以及因此，你知道，我们真的不能相信我们在那之前做出的任何决定。在那之前我们真的不知道自己是谁。以及那种，你知道，你在25岁醒来，突然间，世界就变得有意义了。突然间，这就是真正成年生活开始的时候。我看到网上有很多人描述这种感觉，就像是一种感官上的体验，描述25岁时那种身份和成熟度的地震式转变
almost all at once. And I definitely don't doubt that they're experiencing this. I think I've also felt this way in recent years. It's just not as clear cut as you would think. And it turns out that frontal lobe development age that everybody talks about actually comes from some really, I don't want to say dodgy misrepresented research from like 20 to 30 years ago. And it has since been dissected, dismissed, and kind of revealed to probably not be very accurate. So let's talk about it. Let's begin by actually discussing like what the frontal lobe does. Like why is this part of our brain so essential for essentially determining.
几乎是一瞬间发生的。我绝对不怀疑他们有这种体验。我想我近年来也有这种感觉。只是它并不像你想象的那么明确。事实证明，每个人都在谈论的那个前额叶皮层发育年龄，实际上来自于一些，我不想说是不可靠的，被歪曲的研究，那是20到30年前的。它此后被剖析、驳斥，并被揭示出可能并不准确。所以让我们谈谈它。让我们从讨论前额叶皮层的作用开始。为什么大脑的这一部分对于确定一个人是否成熟，或者确定一个人的大脑是否完全发育如此重要。
that somebody is mature or determining that somebody's brain is fully developed. So your brain has a few lobes. You've probably learned this in like high school science class. It has four lobes, the parietal, temporal, temporal, occipital lobe, and of course the frontal lobe. You can also include the insular and limbic lobes as well if you want to get really technical. If you want to be, really want to impress people, you can say it's six lobes. But the theory essentially goes that each lobe is responsible for different functions and behaviors. Now, even this theory, I have to say, that theory in itself has been hotly debated because I think we now realize, like, the brain is a highly integrated network of cells. It's not like there are four or six little brains in our brain. You know, it's one brain that every area of our brain is constantly communicating. If you were to look inside the brain, like, you wouldn't see any physical walls dividing the different regions. Like, the functions definitely overlap. But,
所以你的大脑有几个叶。你可能在高中科学课上学过这个。它有四个叶，顶叶、颞叶、枕叶，当然还有前额叶。如果你想更专业一点，你也可以加上岛叶和边缘叶。如果你想给别人留下深刻印象，你可以说它是六个叶。但这个理论基本上认为每个叶负责不同的功能和行为。现在，即使是这个理论，我必须说，这个理论本身也一直备受争议，因为我认为我们现在意识到，大脑是一个高度集成的细胞网络。并不是说我们的大脑里有四个或六个小大脑。你知道，这是一个大脑，我们大脑的每个区域都在不断地交流。如果你往大脑里面看，你不会看到任何物理墙壁来划分不同的区域。功能绝对是重叠的。但是，
yeah, there's definitely different things that each lobe does. And the frontal lobe, especially, we definitely know, is deeply responsible for attention, for reasoning, for memory, for identity, and most importantly for this episode, for executive functioning. So executive functioning basically just means your ability to exert control over your actions and impulses and to just, like, think through your decisions, think through your emotions, think through a situation in of you and like come up with a clear idea of what is best for you to do and how to execute that. Now if that area of your brain is, let's say, injured or not developed or underdeveloped, not at its full capacity yet, the logic basically follows that we would have a lot of difficulty
是的，每个叶确实有不同的功能。我们绝对知道，前额叶特别负责注意力、推理、记忆、身份，以及对本集最重要的——执行功能。所以执行功能基本上意味着你对自己的行为和冲动施加控制的能力，以及仅仅是思考你的决定、思考你的情绪、思考你面前的情况，并得出一个关于你该做什么以及如何执行它的清晰想法的能力。现在，如果你的大脑区域，比如说，受伤了，或者没有发育，或者发育不全，还没有达到完全容量，逻辑基本上就是我们会遇到很多困难
performing those same attention, reasoning, memory, executive functioning functions as well. And basically this would explain why, you know, before the age of 25 as this theory goes, before this area of our brain isn't developed. That is why we make stupid decisions. That is why we text our ex when we know we shouldn't. That is why we make random, spontaneous life choices. That is why we do highly irrational things. That is why a man who was 40 dating somebody who was 22 doesn't make sense,
执行同样的注意力、推理、记忆、执行功能。基本上这就解释了为什么，你知道，在25岁之前，按照这个理论，在这个大脑区域没有发育之前。这就是为什么我们做出愚蠢的决定。这就是为什么我们明知不该发短信给前任却还是发了。这就是为什么我们做出随机、自发的生命选择。这就是为什么我们做高度非理性的事情。这就是为什么一个40岁的男人和22岁的人约会说不通，
which literally, yeah, probably true. Actually, absolutely true. And I think there's like parts of that theory that are very comforting, right? because we all do really stupid things in our early 20s. Like, I cannot tell you how many times I have bleached my hair blonde and then dyed it black and then bleached it again and then died it black. And I've cut my bangs a few too many times without ever really thinking it through. Those are just some examples. And, you know, the older I've gotten, the more I, you know, those impulses have kind of lessened.
这字面上，是的，可能确实如此。实际上，绝对是真的。而且我认为这个理论中有一些部分是非常令人欣慰的，对吧？因为我们在20多岁时都做过非常愚蠢的事情。比如，我无法告诉你我漂白头发成金色，然后染成黑色，然后又漂白，然后又染成黑色多少次了。我剪过太多次刘海，却从来没有真正考虑清楚。这些只是几个例子。而且，你知道，我越老，那些冲动就越少。
But does that all happen or did that all happen the moment I'd turn 25? No. And that's because the 25 thing, as I've kind of already revealed, is a myth. And it sometimes becomes a bit of a self-fulfilling prophecy where we definitely feel like we now are adults after that age. But really, that's just the feeling that we are getting from the popularity of this number and from the popularity of this narrative, the narrative behind it isn't actually true. And this is where we need to talk about where this number came from, because it didn't just magically appear what really happened and what it all stems from is this singular study that was done actually I lie not a singular study it was a couple of studies there was one done in 1999 and one done in 2004 by the same group of researchers that looked at brain development from childhood to adolescence particularly what they were looking at was increases and decreases in gray and white matter gray matter is responsible for a lot of thinking, like it's called the thinking matter and decision making. And white matter is kind of what
但这都是在我25岁那一刻发生的吗？不。那是因为25岁这件事，正如我已经揭示的那样，是一个神话。它有时会变成一种自我实现的预言，我们确实觉得我们在那个年龄之后就是成年人了。但实际上，那只是我们从这个数字的流行和这个叙事背后的流行中得到的感觉，它背后的叙事实际上并不真实。这就是我们需要谈论这个数字来源的地方，因为它不是凭空出现的，它真正发生的原因和根源在于这项单一的研究，其实我撒谎了，不是单一的研究，而是几项研究，有一项是在1999年做的，另一项是在2004年由同一组研究人员做的，他们观察了从童年到青春期的大脑发育，他们特别观察的是灰质和白质的增加和减少。灰质负责很多思考，就像它被称为思考物质和决策制定。而白质是那种
carries the messages between the different lobes or parts of your brain. So if you were to see like a cross section of a brain, it's, the white matter is a lot of the stuff in the middle. And in these studies, they wanted to know when our levels of white and gray matter, like reached peak maturity. And so they scanned hundreds of brains, hundreds and hundreds to figure this out. And out. Here's the catch, though. The oldest subject, the oldest person whose brain they scanned, how old do you think they were? 21. They were 21 years old. I think there was a couple of other studies around that time that had a couple 22-year-olds, a couple 23-year-olds, but those most prominent studies, firstly that one in 1999, and then the very famous one in 2004, the oldest
在你的大脑的不同叶或部分之间传递信息的东西。所以如果你看到大脑的横截面，白质是中间的很多东西。在这些研究中，他们想知道我们的白质和灰质水平何时达到成熟的顶峰。所以他们扫描了数百个大脑，数百个，来弄清楚这一点。但是，这里有个陷阱。最年长的受试者，他们扫描大脑的最年长的人，你认为他们多大？21岁。他们21岁。我想那个时期还有几项研究有几个22岁、23岁的人，但那些最著名的研究，首先是1999年的那项，然后是2004年非常著名的一项，最年长的
participant was 21. So where did that 25 number come from? This 25 number that came from this research, well, it came from the author of the paper called J. Geard. I don't know if a G-E-E-D-D, it's G-I-E-D. And he basically speculated and he said, well, I guess it would be 25. If we wanted, based on our research, if we wanted a guess when the brain fully developed, I would say 25. Literally, this is exactly where this comes from. He does this research. He goes and gives a bunch of interviews about this research. And in an interview he does with Time magazine, they ask him, you know, based on what you've been seeing in teenage brains and children's brains and adolescent brains and young adult brains, when do you think the brain fully develops? And he quote, he says, if I had to pick a number
参与者是21岁。那么25岁这个数字是从哪里来的？这个来自这项研究的25岁数字，好吧，它来自论文的作者，名叫J. Geard。我不知道是G-E-E-D-D，还是G-I-E-D。他基本上推测并说，嗯，我猜应该是25岁。如果我们想，基于我们的研究，如果我们想猜测大脑何时完全发育，我会说是25岁。字面上，这就是它的来源。他做了这项研究。他去接受了一堆关于这项研究的采访。在《时代》杂志的一次采访中，他们问他，你知道，基于你在青少年大脑、儿童大脑、青春期大脑和年轻成年人大脑中看到的情况，你认为大脑何时完全发育？他引用说，如果我必须选择一个数字
right now, I'd probably say 25. Now that number stuck because of what a prominent interviewer was. The reason it was really prominent was because at the time, this was in America, they were debating the death penalty and basically like criminal implications for teenagers and for people in their early 20s in the US. And whether people who were 17, 18, 19, 20, 21 could be deemed responsible for their actions given this theory that their brains probably still reflected those. of teenagers. And, you know, why could it... It was basically like, why would somebody who was 15 not be given the death penalty, but somebody
现在，我可能会说是25岁。现在这个数字之所以被记住，是因为采访者非常有名。它之所以非常突出，是因为当时在美国，他们正在辩论死刑，基本上是关于青少年和20多岁的人在美国的刑事责任。以及17、18、19、20、21岁的人是否可以被认为对他们的行为负责，鉴于这个理论，即他们的大脑可能仍然反映了青少年的大脑。而且，你知道，为什么不能……基本上就像，为什么一个15岁的人不被判死刑，但一个
who was 17 be given the death penalty or somebody who was 20 being given the death penalty when, according to our research, like these brains, the brains of these individuals look really, really similar. So it was a huge news story, right? It was a massive news story, and that is where the 25 number comes from.
17岁的人被判死刑，或者一个20岁的人被判死刑，而根据我们的研究，这些大脑，这些人的大脑看起来非常非常相似。所以这是一个巨大的新闻故事，对吧？这是一个巨大的新闻故事，这就是25岁这个数字的来源。
This interview that this guy did, this interview that Jay did, where he said, if I had to choose a number right now, 25, despite the fact that their study did not include anybody who was 25. And specifically to hone on this, like why was it the frontal lobe specifically that develops at 25? Why not the whole brain? Why was there such a focus on this? That is because from that same research, the same scientist discovered that it was the frontal lobe that developed loss. So it just kind of made sense. You know, the frontal lobe was the last piece of the puzzle. When frontal lobe development was done, they said brain development was done.
这个家伙做的这个采访，Jay做的这个采访，他说，如果我现在必须选择一个数字，25，尽管他们的研究没有包括任何25岁的人。特别要指出的是，为什么是前额叶皮层在25岁发育？为什么不是整个大脑？为什么会有这样的关注？这是因为从同一项研究中，同一位科学家发现是前额叶皮层最后发育。所以这有点说得通。你知道，前额叶皮层是拼图的最后一块。当前额叶皮层发育完成时，他们说大脑发育就完成了。
You know, when the frontal lobe clicked into place, that's when people could be seen as responsible. You know, emotionally, morally, most importantly, criminally. So that is the origin of the myth. I also think that there is something to be said about the fact that 25 is a really nice number, right? 25 is a very solid, clean, neat number. And that attracted a lot of attention. You know, he didn't say 24 years and 11 months. He didn't say 26 years and four days.
你知道，当前额叶皮层到位时，人们才会被视为负责任。你知道，在情感上、道德上，最重要的是，在刑事上。所以这就是这个神话的起源。我也认为，25岁是一个非常好的数字，这一点值得一提，对吧？25是一个非常扎实、干净、整洁的数字。这吸引了很多关注。你知道，他没有说24岁11个月。他没有说26岁4天。
He didn't even say 25 years and one, I don't know, one quarter. He gave us one simple, neat, attractive number. And people love that kind of certainty and that kind of simplicity when it comes to describing something as confusing and complex as brain developed. It is the same reason why the myth that we only use 10% of our brain is so popular, because 10% is a nice simple number. Same with the myth that people are 90% water. Simple number. The thing is, actually pinpointing when the brain develops for real is incredibly, incredibly difficult because it differs from person to person based on genetics, based on environment, based on experiences, even based on exposure to things like alcohol.
他甚至没有说25岁零，我不知道，四分之一。他给了我们一个简单、整洁、有吸引力的数字。人们喜欢那种确定性和那种简单性，当涉及到描述像大脑发育这样令人困惑和复杂的事情时。这就是为什么我们只使用大脑10%的神话如此流行的原因，因为10%是一个很好的简单数字。人们是90%的水这个神话也是如此。简单的数字。问题是，实际上准确指出大脑何时真正发育是非常非常困难的，因为它因人而异，基于遗传、环境、经历，甚至基于对酒精等事物的接触。
it's also gradual. Yes, like there is a point where your brain will reach peak maturity. But it's kind of what we call like a bold man conundrum. I don't know if you've heard this like this kind of exercise before, but essentially there's this like debate around how many hairs does a man have to have before he's no longer bald? You know, if there was a man in front of you and he had one hair, one single hair, you would think he was bald. What if he had five hairs? Probably or bald? What if you had 500 hairs? You know, there is a point at which one additional hair stops that man from being bald. And I know that sounds like a weird analogy for brain development, but there is a point where one slight neural change takes somebody's brain from not developed to
它也是渐进的。是的，确实有一个点，你的大脑会达到成熟的顶峰。但这有点像我们所说的“秃头难题”。我不知道你以前是否听说过这种练习，但本质上，关于一个人在不再秃头之前必须有多少根头发，存在着这种争论。你知道，如果你面前有一个人，他有一根头发，一根头发，你会认为他是秃头。如果他有五根头发呢？可能还是秃头？如果他有500根头发呢？你知道，有一个点，多一根头发就会阻止那个人成为秃头。我知道这听起来像是大脑发育的一个奇怪的类比，但确实有一个点，一个轻微的神经变化使某人的大脑从没发育变成
developed. So that's like the interesting thing. That is going to be different for everybody. The other thing is that the brain continues to change across the lifespan. New paths are constantly being paved, old paths are scrapped, we lose and gain white matter due to learning and changes in our lives. So is our brain ever fully developed? Yes, but is it also constantly a work in progress? Also, yes. Like, what does development really look like? Like, what does that peak look like? This is what the science says these days. When is our brain fully developed? Actually, just last year, they kind of got as close as they ever have to answering that question. and they did it in the most roundabout confusing way possible because of course they do.
发育了。所以这就是有趣的事情。这对每个人来说都是不同的。另一件事是，大脑在整个生命周期中都在不断变化。新的路径不断被铺设，旧的路径被废弃，由于学习和我们生活中的变化，我们失去和获得白质。所以我们的大脑真的完全发育了吗？是的，但它是否也一直在进行中？也是，是的。就像，发育到底是什么样子的？就像，那个顶峰是什么样子的？这就是现在的科学所说的。我们的大脑何时完全发育？实际上，就在去年，他们以最迂回、最令人困惑的方式尽可能接近地回答了这个问题，因为他们当然会这样做。
The study was called, the study that kind of concluded not once and for all, but pretty solidly what is actually happening, is called topological turning points across the human lifespan. It was a study conducted out of Cambridge. If you follow me on Instagram, you may have seen me talking about this study recently, but essentially these researchers analysed the brain scans of more than 4,000 people from infancy, all the way up to 90 years old. So no, they didn't just stop at 21. And they specifically looked at white matter changes. Here is what they found. Your brain basically has several spurts or key periods of development across the lifespan. And in each of those periods, different things are occurring.
这项研究被称为，这项研究，它不是一劳永逸地，但相当扎实地总结了实际发生的事情，被称为“人类生命周期中的拓扑转折点”。这是一项在剑桥进行的研究。如果你在Instagram上关注我，你可能最近看到我谈论这项研究，但本质上这些研究人员分析了4000多名从婴儿期一直到90岁的人的大脑扫描。所以不，他们没有止步于21岁。他们专门观察了白质的变化。这是他们发现的。你的大脑在整个生命周期中基本上有几个突发期或关键发育期。在每一个时期，都会发生不同的事情。
The four turning points that we need to know are ages nine, ages 32, age 66 and age 83. So between zero and nine, your brain is just like building as much as it possibly can. It's growing very, very rapidly. Between nine and 32, which they actually, they call the adolescence period, even though it's not just the teenage years. That is when your brain starts to prune. It starts to build different neighborhoods of neurons and thought processes and it integrates those neighborhoods. It gets really, really organized. It starts to kind of get closer to optimizing and gets closer to being able to reason through all of its thoughts. But, Between 32 and 66 is when it gets the most efficient and it begins to specialize.
我们需要知道的四个转折点是9岁、32岁、66岁和83岁。所以在0到9岁之间，你的大脑就像在尽可能多地建设。它生长得非常非常快。在9到32岁之间，他们实际上称之为青春期，尽管它不仅仅是青少年时期。那是你的大脑开始修剪的时候。它开始建立不同的神经元和思维过程的邻里，并整合这些邻里。它变得非常非常有组织。它开始有点接近优化，并接近能够通过其所有思想进行推理。但是，在32到66岁之间，它是最有效率的时候，并开始专业化。
Basically, things start to really feel locked in. That's when we're perfecting pathways. After 63, the core areas of our brain and those core pathways become more important. All the other, like, kind of medium and small important pathways around and different circuits become less important. So basically, it's organizing and it's consolidating even deeper. And after the age of 83 is when we see a lot of. of neural decline, loss of gray and white matter, and it's when we see central pathways really become the main pathways. So if you think about it, like almost like the building of a society,
基本上，事情开始真正感觉锁定。那是我们完善路径的时候。63岁之后，我们大脑的核心区域和那些核心路径变得更加重要。所有其他，像，中等和小型的重要路径以及不同的电路变得不那么重要。所以基本上，它在组织，并且在更深地巩固。83岁之后，我们看到了很多神经衰退，灰质和白质的损失，这是我们看到中央路径真正成为主要路径的时候。所以如果你考虑一下，就像建设一个社会，
zero to nine is when like everybody's like pitching tense, like everybody's just trying to figure out what's going on, like there's all these disparate areas, all these different regions and like they're not very connected and it's like kind of rudimentary. Then like that second period, nine to 32 is when, you know, we start building some roads between the towns. Like, things start to get a bit more coherent. 32 to 63 is when like, yeah, we've got major buildings going up. We've got a highway. We've got every, all the structures like are good to go after 63 to 83.
0到9岁是每个人都在搭帐篷的时候，每个人都只是试图弄清楚发生了什么，有所有这些不同的区域，所有这些不同的区域，它们连接得不是很好，而且有点基础。然后像第二个时期，9到32岁是当我们开始在城镇之间修路的时候。事情开始变得有点连贯。32到63岁是当我们有主要建筑拔地而起的时候。我们有高速公路。我们有所有的结构，一切都准备好了，63到83岁之后。
It's like, oh, you know, people kind of, you know, we're getting, like, the people kind of moving out of town. You know, they don't really use all those little suburban streets we built for them. It really just me, they use like, you know, a couple of main roads. and 83 onwards is like the town is now bypassed by a highway. There's like a couple of roads that run through. Those are the ones that are used. All those little disparate neighborhoods are no longer really supported.
就像，哦，你知道，人们有点，你知道，我们正在，人们有点搬出城镇。你知道，他们并不真正使用我们为他们建造的所有那些小郊区街道。他们真的只是使用，你知道，几条主要道路。83岁以后就像城镇现在被高速公路绕过了。有几条路穿过。那些是使用的。所有那些分散的小邻里不再真正得到支持。
That's like the best way I can think of explaining it. What the study basically found is that there is not one final age we land at and we are good to go. We are changing in different ways across our lives based on our neural and environmental and social and emotional and mental needs. It also says that, you know, if you are in your 20s right now, which I'm pretty sure you are, I'm going to take a well-informed guess considering you're looking or you're listening to this podcast, don't feel like you are locked in. Like, you will continue to be in a state of exploration and change and growth until your mid-30s.
这是我能想到的解释它的最好方式。这项研究基本上发现，没有一个我们最终到达并准备就绪的最终年龄。我们根据我们的神经、环境、社会、情感和心理需求在我们的生活中以不同的方式变化。它还说，你知道，如果你现在20多岁，我很确定你是，我会做一个消息灵通的猜测，考虑到你正在看或听这个播客，不要觉得你被锁定了。你将继续处于探索、变化和成长的状态，直到30多岁。
And then after that, you will continue to be in a state of optimization until your 60s. If you're in your mid-20s and you're waiting for that epiphany that comes with your frontal lobe developing for good, you know, you may have to wait a little bit longer. That is a good thing. What this study also talked about is how much we are at an advantage during this period to shift and change and really influence, you know, what pathways are strengthened and which pathways are abandoned. So you need to make the most of your brain right now by giving it as many experiences and learning opportunities as possible because you are in your prime. You are building the society of your brain. I also think it's scary in some ways. Obviously, it's scary to be like,
然后在那之后，你将继续处于优化状态，直到60多岁。如果你在20多岁，正在等待前额叶皮层发育带来的顿悟，你知道，你可能需要再等一会儿。这是一件好事。这项研究还谈到了我们在这一时期在转变和改变以及真正影响，你知道，哪些路径被加强，哪些路径被放弃方面有多大的优势。所以你需要现在充分利用你的大脑，给它尽可能多的经验和学习机会，因为你正处于黄金时期。你正在建设你的大脑社会。我也认为它在某些方面很可怕。显然，像这样很可怕，
oh my God, I've got to wait a little bit longer. And also, oh, my God, it's scary to think that after 32, I can't make as many changes as I could now. You can continue to make changes. There is no magical switch. You get to keep learning, keep developing much longer than you probably anticipated. And obviously, like, the older you get, the more you will start to make more informed decisions. and the more you'll be able to feel like you have more control over your life. So I think all of this is actually a good thing. As long as you are feeding your brain newness and novelty and even like actually engaging in the spontaneity of this time in your life,
哦我的天，我得再等一会儿。而且，哦，我的天，想到32岁以后我不能像现在这样做出那么多改变，这很可怕。你可以继续做出改变。没有神奇的开关。你比你预期的要长得多地继续学习、继续发展。显然，你越老，你就会开始做出更多知情的决定。你越能感觉到你对自己的生活有更多的控制权。所以我认为所有这些实际上是一件好事。只要你在喂养你的大脑新鲜感和新奇感，甚至像实际上参与你生命中这段时间的自发性，
I actually think you're totally winning. Of course, like after 32, we can still continue to do that. We still will make dumb decisions. But I think the same drive and impulse won't be there. And that is a huge perk of being young. your willingness to explore and to take risks and just to follow impulse and follow desire and follow passion is a huge part of this period that you're in right now, not just in terms of your life, but in terms of your brain development. So there you go, guys. This is the frontal lobe
我实际上认为你完全赢了。当然，32岁以后，我们仍然可以继续这样做。我们仍然会做出愚蠢的决定。但我认为同样的驱动力和冲动不会在那里。这是年轻的一个巨大好处。你探索和冒险的意愿，以及仅仅跟随冲动、跟随欲望和跟随激情的意愿，是你现在所处的这个时期的重要组成部分，不仅是在你的生活方面，而且是在你的大脑发育方面。所以给你，伙计们。这就是前额叶皮层
myth decoded for you. Next time somebody like makes a comment about it at a party or like makes a meme about it online, you know, you can be that annoying, no at all, who corrects them, or at least like the person with the fun fact that, hey, no, your brain does not, or your frontal lobe does not fully develop at 25. You got at least seven more years before that takes place, maybe even longer. I hope you enjoyed this little bonus episode. I'm not going to ramble or rant for much longer because I want to keep it short and sweet for you guys. Yeah, I hope you enjoyed this episode. I actually had so much fun researching it. I feel like some of my favorite episodes and where we get to myth bust, like, certain psychology things, because it's, you get to go
神话为你解码。下次有人在聚会上对此发表评论或在网上制作关于它的模因时，你知道，你可以成为那个烦人的、什么都知道的人，纠正他们，或者至少是那个有有趣事实的人，嘿，不，你的大脑不会，或者你的前额叶皮层不会在25岁完全发育。在那发生之前你至少还有七年，甚至可能更长。我希望你喜欢这个小奖励节目。我不会再唠叨或咆哮太久了，因为我想为你们保持简短和甜蜜。是的，我希望你喜欢这一集。我实际上在研究它时玩得很开心。我觉得我最喜欢的一些节目，以及我们能够揭穿神话的地方，比如某些心理学的东西，因为它是，你可以去
into so much, like, history as well, like the history of the death penalty in the US. Who would know? Who would think that the death penalty in the US and Leonardo DiCaprio memes would have the same origin point, which is this one study done in freaking, in the early 2000s. So, there you go. Fun fact to end or start your day with. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram. Make sure that you, if you enjoyed this episode and you want to watch some episodes, not this one, unfortunately, but many, many others, you can actually watch us on Netflix. I feel like a lot of my regular listeners know this by now.
深入了解很多，像历史，比如美国死刑的历史。谁会知道？谁会想到美国的死刑和莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥的模因会有相同的起源点，也就是这项在2000年代初做的研究。所以，给你。以一个有趣的事实结束或开始你的一天。确保你在Instagram上关注我们。确保你，如果你喜欢这一集并且你想看一些节目，不是这一集，不幸的是，但很多很多其他的，你实际上可以在Netflix上观看我们。我觉得我的很多常客现在都知道这一点。
But yes, we are all of our episodes, our video episodes are available on Netflix for you to watch. So you can go and see our cool backdrop, our cool, a little studio. It's a very, very cute. What else do I have to say? Substack. I don't, oh, my God, I always forget. There's always so many things on the list now of like, who do I need to thank? Thanks to you guys for listening.
但是是的，我们所有的节目，我们的视频节目都可以在Netflix上供你观看。所以你可以去看看我们很酷的背景，我们很酷的，小工作室。它非常非常可爱。我还有什么要说的？Substack。我没有，哦，我的天，我总是忘记。现在名单上总是有这么多事情，比如，我需要感谢谁？感谢你们收听。
There you go. You guys never get to thank you. You can have a thank you today. Thank you for listening. Thank you for making it to the end if you made it this far. Leave a little brain emoji down below if you are listening on Spotify. But yeah, until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon.
给你。你们永远不会得到感谢。你今天可以得到一个感谢。感谢收听。如果你走到这一步，感谢你走到最后。如果你在Spotify上收听，在下面留下一个大脑表情符号。但是的，直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔。我们很快很快就会谈话。
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Creveth and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty.
那些眼睛里空无一物。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒吧。我是那个目睹了谋杀案发生的人，凶手是Creveth和DePippo。安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）在被判处最高刑罚后毫无悔意，显得泰然自若。我说我没有罪。
I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is a set. and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free iHeart radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CVS.
我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。在Bone Valley订阅源中收听《魔鬼采石场》，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。快乐是必须的。而且它也难以捉摸，但现在有一种令人兴奋的新方式来开启您通往更快乐生活的旅程——《快乐101》。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby）主持的新播客。如果您渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的节目。打开您免费的iHeart radio应用程序。搜索《快乐101》并立即收听。《快乐101》与霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby）由CVS呈现。
Everyone sees me as a football player But before anything else, I'm human Every single day I'm still learning How to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive.
每个人都视我为足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何面对问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、纯粹的。只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。
I'm Javier Tchariot Hernandez And listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month And on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are?
我是哈维尔·埃尔南德斯（Javier Hernandez），请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Chams》播客中，我们正在与文化界最热门的人物交谈，比如斯韦·李（Swae Lee）。你意识到你有多传奇了吗？
I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped, like, 30 albums. We dropped, like, five right now. Like, that's the rate we gotta be going. Yeah, that's a good attitude. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations.
我很感激。我看到了，但我还是觉得，伙计，我还有很多事情要做。比如王子（Prince），他发行了大约30张专辑。我们现在才发行了大约5张。这就是我们必须达到的速度。是的，那是个好态度。无论什么时代，《Drink Chams》都会为您带来最大牌的嘉宾和最直白的对话。
Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city, in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people.
请收听来自黑人效应播客网络（Black Effect Podcast Network）的《Drink Chams》，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听。这里有一些事情不应该像现在这样复杂，比如移除种族主义雕像。这里有一些事情应该比现在容易得多，比如在原处放置一个新的。我是阿凯拉·休斯（Akela Hughes），《反叛精神》第二季就是关于这两件事的。当我看着这些雕像被拆除时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大，那里对奴隶主的致敬比对被奴役的人的致敬还要多，这意味着什么。
Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《反叛精神》第二季。这是一个IHeart播客，保证真人。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。